[Music]
the US government is taking a closer
look at how to stop hackers from taking
control of medical devices like
pacemakers
an inspector general's report last month
found the Food and Drug Administration's
plans and processes were deficient for
addressing medical device cybersecurity
compromises the FDA disputes that and
says it has worked proactively on the
issue and a Warner shows us how the
agency is now coordinating with hackers
to detect potential problems
that's an interesting tactic and a good
morning yeah good morning well many
people may not realize that medical
devices some of them run on computers
and like computers they can be hacked
now so far neither government officials
nor security experts have identified any
incidents in which a computer hacker has
harmed a patient through a medical
device but these cyber security
researchers say those devices have
massive vulnerabilities that make it
easy for hackers to break in there's
nothing stopping us from in a garage
taking them apart and hacking them
nothing talk to Billy Rios and Jonathan
Butz about the security of medical
devices and we've yet to find a device
that we've looked at that we haven't
been able to hack wait you're yet to
find a medical device that you cannot
hack that is correct the two security
researchers have examined critical
machines like pacemakers drug infusion
pumps and insulin pumps devices that
help keep people alive and found all
have vulnerabilities that would allow
someone else to take control of the
machines the reason all of those devices
are run by computers and computers can
be hacked this is all kind of that's why
we do this right so for instance take
this insulin pump made by device
manufacturer Medtronic anyone that has
this device that has one of these
controllers we can take it over they
showed us how they can send a wireless
signal telling the pump to deliver the
wrong amount of insulin to a patient
nearby who might be wearing it so you're
in control of this out
you're not pushing the buttons on that
I'm not pushing but even if you were I
won't do anything
they also found vulnerabilities in a
Medtronic pacemaker that could allow a
hacker to reprogram the device from
anywhere disrupting a patient's heart
rhythms in a way that could hurt or kill
them
they're scenarios that until now have
been the stuff of TV shows it sounds
like a method for murder am i right yeah
there's I mean there's no coming back
from some of these exploits right so if
a pacemaker for patient gets hacked you
can't take that back
you can't issue them a new credit card
you can't tell them to change their
password you can't issue them credit
monitoring they're hurt they're killed
the pacemaker vulnerability was serious
enough they thought Medtronic would want
to address it immediately so in January
of 2017 they sent the company a report
detailing what they'd found it seemed to
us that a lot of it was being downplayed
by the manufacturer
when you say downplayed what do you mean
I mean they were saying hey this isn't
this isn't possible it's not feasible in
the way that they characterize is wrong
and so they were just completely
disagreeing with everything so the two
researchers decided they had to prove it
by writing the code thank you then
demonstrating the potential dangers of
both the pacemaker and the insulin pump
at a prestigious information security
conference after the two live
demonstrations people actually stood up
and clapped which was it kind of took us
by surprise Medtronic's response the
company issued a statement saying it had
addressed the problem and that existing
security controls mitigate the issue but
the vulnerability caught the attention
of the Food and Drug Administration any
device can be hacked and that's often
not understood the FDA's dr. Suzanne
Schwartz oversees medical device
cybersecurity
she says manufacturers have been playing
catch-up it's a culture shift so the
actions and the activities that we're
seeing manufacturers take are very
encouraging they're very promising but
we still have a ways to go in the case
of the Medtronic pacemaker the
researchers work prompted the FDA to
start asking questions of its own
that was when Medtronic finally came out
and said what we've been saying all
along was indeed correct that there is
remote concern and there is potential
constipation home last month the FDA
took action sending out a warning about
certain Medtronic pacemakers and the
company issued a software fix Medtronic
has also instructed users of its insulin
pumps to disable certain features to
minimize risks the company declined an
on-camera interview but in a statement
to CBS News Medtronic admitted it took
entirely too long to process validate
and mitigate the vulnerabilities
discovered by the two researchers so do
you feel vindicated I mean I'm looking
for vintage yeah you know at the end of
the day for those manufacturers that
don't want to move and don't want to fix
their devices I hope they realized that
the repercussions are really serious and
we can't wait for something to happen
before they decide to try to fix
something
well Medtronic told us it began taking
some steps to mitigate the vulnerability
risks even before Rios and buses live
demonstrations it also told us it has
significantly improved its response time
to reports of vulnerabilities that
insulin pump however is still in use
though the company claims it's being
phased out now to learn more about the
vulnerabilities that have been found and
what can be done about it you can visit
CBS this morning
dot-com but the FDA is now working with
these two researchers and others to try
to catch these things before anybody can
do anything with them to hurts me is
there any sign that people are doing
this that are hacking them in in order
to harm people
well that's the thing is they're trying
to get out ahead of it they don't have
any case specific cases that they know
about right now but they don't want to
wait until it happens and yeah thank you
after Rios and mr. butts I saw it on a
TV show thought that's a TV show now it
ain't a TV show on homeland is right
thank you Anna